luno the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys and welcome back to my
show today is going to be really interesting
so just bear with us because this is powered by
icon plus so a really quick news announcement for
you so this quarter icon will not only launch
d5 projects omn finance and balance but also
upgrade to icon 2.0 so this will be really
interesting now this is um sponsored by
blockbuy you can earn up to 8.6 interest on your
usdc um on your usdc i said that really weirdly
um and you can actually get i think it's around
250 when you sign up so check that out now guys
if you are watching on youtube please don't forget
to hit the subscribe button hit the like button
so you never miss any of these interesting guests
now today for the very first time we actually have
somebody who is just a little bit younger than me
usually i'm always the youngest in the room but
it is young investor how are you doing zach what's
up thanks hand me on yeah of course i've just been
seeing you around seeing you grow so much online
and i'm kind of just amazed that you're 13 right
yeah 13 now so i have so many questions for you
um and i kind of just want to start really with
being 13 and being in you know stocks and
crypto and all this stuff is so unusual
so you must get people who are so surprised when
you tell them you're 13. what's the first reaction
you get well it's kind of like so you know you
get you get your goodness bad side of people
you know you've got your haters then you've got
like the 99 of people who are really positive
so like obviously all the positive people always
like that you know that's amazing i'm really
surprised i mean right now i've done like three
straight interviews on my youtube channel but
i didn't want ross gerber he runs a 1.6 billion
dollar hedge fund and gally from hyperchange and
i just got daily on investing on and then you know
everyone's commenting about saying how much they
love the guests on so it's all going really really
well right now and just there's not a surprise
it's also not people who just you know are really
um in a sense they just think well you know it's
how can you be into stocks at that young age and
you're somebody put in the comments the other day
and he i my dad used to tax me 13 when i was like
at his age on all my winnings so yeah so you know
you always get your mixed reactions but all 99
always positive i'm just so blown away because
you know you're on twitter which is just really
just an adult's playground like that's just the
truth of it and how do you find it how do you
find that you know especially there's a lot of
different ideas on there there's a lot of um
conversations you know it gets very political
um crypto gets really political stocks get really
political so how do you find sort of navigating
through that and interacting with everyone yeah
well i think if you're on twitter you've always
got to be prepared for you know a bit of hate or
else don't be on twitter you know i think you this
kind of thing where if you're really sensitive
about something then you've just shouldn't be
on twitter but i think chris is such a place with
so many fluid conversations happening you know you
have one person about crypto one person talking
about stocks two people have both long bitcoin
arguing about bitcoin i think it's actually a
fascinating place to see other people's opinions
and perspectives on the world in general whether
that's from stocks crypto or anything else maybe
somewhere abroad or um you know current events
you always get everyone's perspective on twitter
i think that's what really makes the platform
special okay so what about your friends you
know are they into this as well or do they think
what you're doing is absolutely nuts and insane
yes i mean my friends aren't you know don't really
care to be honest they're just kind of like i'll
call them you know we'll do our normal stuff
whatever we do so if i go you know for a little
for a ride with one of them you know socks doesn't
come up in the conversation or crypto because it's
one most complicated and boring things in the
entire world if you don't know anything about
it you know so i think if you just stay away
from that kind of conversation topic constantly
then you know it's it's all fun and games really
yeah i love that i love that attitude even in my
own life my friends are not interested in bitcoin
whatsoever um so yeah you just you just stay away
from it so okay so you say it's you know boring
to everyone else so how did you first get into it
yeah so i used to be a really full full-blown
history geek and you you're sure you know the
rothschilds they built the very first ever
network which would be able to communicate
the best news really quickly say the whole
team of messengers which will communicate
the wins so when napoleon was against the duke
of wellington in the battlefields of france in
waterloo obviously we won that battle which then
saved us from french invasion but the ross child
sent a messenger back to london because everyone
used to rely on their network as most reliable
and quickest even quicker than the military's
network when they came to london they said that we
lost the battle of water though the stock market
proceeded to plunge 80 percent as everyone wanted
to get their money out and flee abroad before the
french marched on london and then obviously the
rothschilds completely lied and brought up all
the stocks when they were down 80 a few people
actually caught on to it on the stock exchange
and started buying it up as well and obviously
in stock market immediately around rebounded
the rothschilds made a whole lot of money so
it's kind of things with that when you hear about
all this kind of stuff in history which really
inspired me to fight open a stock market account
and then further on and then a crypto account
so given you know you're doing all this stuff
and you've obviously opened up the crypto account
and things like that what i'm really interested in
asking you about really is is there any financial
education in school i know you've probably been
out of school for ages because of covert and all
that stuff but do they talk about this in school
these days i mean you know bitcoin's going crazy
is it even on the syllabus yeah so i've been
at school for about three or four weeks now
and i've just finished now for easter holidays for
two weeks so you never hear a word about stocks or
bitcoin at school there's nothing there's no kind
of financial education at all this sets up so the
education system really lacks i mean i think you
know investing and investing just where that's
bitcoin whether that's another asset it's just
the key to grow wealth in the future and you're
older and older you get it's just simple math by
compound interest wherever you want to take a risk
and invest in so much bitcoin which might be more
speculative or not for your risk tolerance whether
you want to invest in something which i don't know
might be the s p 500 index funds either one of
those ways is really a way to grow wealth now i do
think that lacks in the current education system
so do you think that they're ever gonna bring
that in do you think that do you feel a need to
sort of because like you said it's the best way to
grow wealth and you know um ensure your future and
so on so do you think that eventually they're
gonna bring that in and also do you suddenly
feel like a moral need to share your wisdom with
your friends and other people at school with you
yeah i mean um i do think that it depends you
i think you need someone in government he's
just all really into this kind of stuff to have
that push through so i kind of doubt it comes
into the education system in the near future it's
lacked in the education system last like 100 years
you know these days it's kind of thing where you
know the whole modern environment has changed
back when my name was alive in world war ii you
know when they didn't have running water hot water
and then the bomb then the bombs were falling down
compared to now when it's all online or technology
hence you're streaming live onto twitter and
youtube all through technology or for computers
cameras so i think it's just really an
era of which has changed so the education
has changed with that era but i do think
that one thing which hasn't really changed
just financial education to people i mean i my
friends like know about all my socks and all that
but i don't i don't push it just because i feel
like if it's not something you're interested in
it's not something you're really really interested
in i think it's always kind of a bad idea if you
constantly push it on someone because then you
don't get any friends because i think you've got
listen to what other people think about what their
interests are as well but i do think that um when
i put my stuff out on twitter youtube where there
might be i always hope that some some kids somehow
get inspired i was out in my um in the precinct
like a few weeks it's like yeah last sunday
and some kid who looked how like looked like he's
about 11 came up to me and said hey you're a young
investor i was like wow yeah and that was the um
i said he said oh he loves my youtube live streams
i've never met him before so that's that's that's
that's the only other time i've been recognized
but it was um pretty cool it's just seeing like
that how you inspire people to get into investing
you know i think it's absolutely phenomenal
more and more people investing the more and
more wealthier you're going to be in that sense
and the quicker you can retire and the longer
you can be retired for instead of working like
the whole 60 years of your life is you know the
retirement age carries on going up okay so how
do you have this wisdom though like how do you
know about that because look you're talking about
inflation you're talking about early retirement
you're talking about things which a lot of people
only in their mid-20s come to so i'm in my mid-20s
and i'm i feel like i'm quite lucky because i
kind of figured this out when i was about 22
and i think that's really really young um so how
on earth did you come to all of this wisdom i mean
did your parents talk to you about you know
i don't know early retirement because also
with all this you know following and with
all with this following that you have and
with um because you have a really engaged
following so with this and following that
that you have and you know with all this financial
wisdom and all this investing you're carving out
the most incredible future for yourself yes so my
parents like know nothing about finance especially
my mother wow yeah i started investing just from
like i described earlier about all about history
and i mean i had like nuclear what i was doing
it was awfully kind of youtube how i learned
how to invest and through the odds like books
so you can see a book by peter lynch back
there so it's kind of just for youtube i do think
youtube's kind of the new university you can learn
everything you really learn at university on
youtube so i really learned everything about
the stock market on youtube so it's kind
of progressed from the stage where nine or
nine or ten months ago i was just investing in
whatever so now it's kind of like i actually
dig deep into companies i might get to see on my
channel and actually dig a dig deeper and take
that next step into researching into companies
and actually deciding which ones are the frauds
and which ones are the next big thing and you
know next really 10x opportunity in the markets
so so that's really how i just look at it all and
i mean my the only other time my dad's invested
was something like 40 years ago when hit my dad
put some money into like virgin group or something
when the ibo ipos yeah i think it's like he was
like 20 then but in the richard branson ticket
like public that's private again one week later
because of share price didn't do what he hoped
so um i kind of off like maybe a month after
investing i got my dad into it i think he's
like yeah i love that yeah so now hopefully
it's more more and more people get into
investing you know the more wealth you grow
and all in like long 30 or 40 year time span
so given what you said about university you know
youtube is the is the new university especially if
you're not you know if you're not doing something
like medicine and law then everything else i think
generally speaking is good on youtube so do you
have what are your plans do you have plans no one
have even thought about it and do you have plans
to go to university or are you just building you
yeah i mean i i just take it as it goes i mean
right now i've got my money and all my cryptos
and my stocks on one side so it's kind of like
more and more you build that i'm aiming for a
kind of aggressive but hopefully i won't one year
salary by the time at 18 saved up so that's kind
of the way you do where i'm trying to not try
not to go university in that sense i mean if
i want to go university it's always there there's
no time limit as soon as you're like 25 you can't
go university it's always there if i want to but
maybe you know take it take it as it goes in time
yeah i think i can't give you any advice i can
just give you really informal opinions which is
ditch university and just do what you're doing
honestly i just think what you're doing is so
amazing you're obviously so intelligent and
i think everyone is just like so impressed so
how do you pick a stock then
what are the best stocks for 2021
i mean the the really first way i look at stocks
is you know as long as the financials are sound
it's got at least really like two years
worth of cash from the balance sheet
or it's going to have enough in profit to boost
that up i'm trying to look for companies in the
lowest which are growing super high growth and
extremely undervalued compared to the amount
of money or revenue they're going to make this
year we're going to try and get as low as the
p as possible so if you look at something like i
don't know upstart so which is like 20 pa i don't
invest in that kind of company i want to invest in
a company which is like super undervalued whether
that's on otc markets whether it's just on the
normal exchanges but saying which has just been
super um overlooked by investors so right now one
of my biggest high conventional trades right now
it's a company called peak fintech holdings
they're gonna be uplifting to the nasdaq in
a few weeks and they basically are in china and
they allow small family-run businesses to connect
with these massive lenders in china and take some
take small loans out between them so that will
help boost like the family business for example
but when the chinese lenders aren't all online are
on all advanced as technology is right now they
are enabling that to happen there's also canadian
technically canadian based it's founded by a
canadian person called jj so you've got that
risk where you don't get the d listing because
it's based in canada not in china so you don't
get kind of trying to delisting fiasco they are
expected i would i estimate around 250 million
dollars in revenue this year i'll expect for
guidance in a few weeks ever say around 150
and you know for the last few years they always
set their expectations super low for kind of the
um you know settle kind of over deliver not
um over promise and under deliver so that's
really kind of their whole moral to you know so
investors are in sense more pleased than rather
all disappointed when you might be with some
specs at the moment which aren't reaching those
kind of highs that you want them to so companies
are around 320 million dollars right now so if
they were to get 250 million in revenue it's just
a super cheap market cap market cap right now you
know 10 pe or 11 is really not unreasonable on a
company growing as fast as this 600 year-over-year
if they hit 250 million this year and so like 300
last year so you're in an industry where and all
kinds of growth rates it's fintech and you've got
super ips super high things which are pricing in
a lot of the growth compared to coming like this
is super undervalued in the whole marketplace
so that's really how i can look pick socks
i'm looking for the ones which are super
overlooked you know you don't you when i look
at peak fintech there's no articles about them
you've got to really do and really
deep digging and that's kind of
stock i want i don't think there's hardly any
analysts covering out and i'd like zero analysts
covering the stock at all which is one of the best
times to invest because the smart money isn't in
yet uplifts the nasdaq means institutions start
to buy in 50 million race to complete institutions
so then that won't affect the float which is the
amount of which can be traded on a daily basis
those institutions will be locked up so they
won't be able to trade this stock which will
mean there's no pressure on the current stock
price with a float right now it just adds to
the outstanding shares which which combined will
equal the whole market cap so i'm just looking for
a super overlooked company super undervalued
which has a super high growth trajectory
and would you call yourself i know obviously
you've called yourself young investor but do you
are you more of a trader then or an investor
like how long are you holding on to these stocks
yeah so with the kind of like tests which
is not like 40 of my stock portfolio that's
kind of a free four-year long-term poll for me
that's kind of the backbone that's the strength
you know super bullish from tesla what they're
doing is actually transforming the world ev's
thomas driving us all the future they're far
ahead then all the competition and behind them
and you know look at gm look up for they're not
taking the ev revolution seriously so tess is kind
of the backbone at 40 percent strong company super
bullish on it super bullish on elon so that's with
that so that's there at 40 then something like
um peak fintech which might be a maybe a one
to two year hold so something like that this is
more speculative if for example at 5x tomorrow
or like 5x in the next year then i'd really
kind of reassess the whole situation with peak
what they're gonna make next year and this
is kind of the point where harry said this
is a bit overvalued now i would sell out and if
it's not i would keep unit out of something like
went to like that 40 of my portfolio if it's
still in kind of the fair price range for peak
and if i was just getting into stock
i'd be buying it at those kind of prices
so with some like tesla which is just super
long term i might evaluate like just three as
three other stocks which are like the main holes
in my portfolio are komodo which is an ev company
clean smart which is basically transforming
the micro grids microgrids enable you to
so in the main power grid goes down slowly over
time microgrids have been draining power from
whether that's your solar panels or the main
network and that can keep your house military
and military base carrying running for a certain
amount of time combined with this they recently
brought a bitcoin mining division so they're gonna
aim to scale up to seven eight bitcoins a day that
same as mara but mars like five six x higher
than clean sparking valuation and just with that
they're combining the microgrids and the bitcoin
mining to try and make the lowest cost of mining
bitcoin in the industry which then means on top of
that you can then license all this technology to
all the other bitcoin players so that's even more
revenue on top of bitcoin mining and micro grids
then you're also doing bitcoin licensing or the
mining so i'm just looking for something which is
super undervalued but if there's a company which
may be more speculative so which isn't a tester in
my portfolio that's where i i re-evaluate it
every single earnings and see if the story's
changed is his stories changed and you want to
get out of it if it's no longer what you are um
wanting the trajectory for the company to go on
and if it's not then you keep and then you hold
so you mentioned the three that take up the
majority of your portfolio right now but
what would you potentially can you name on some
stocks that you're looking at for the next for
the rest of 2021 can you give us any clues yeah
so so my main stock right now for 2021 is peak i
just think peaks are undervalued it is one thing
with it everything went into the domino effect
that could be a 10x stock in like two years if the
market picks up on it and starts to realize it and
as soon as you get the up list and the nasdaq just
how undervalued it is it's absolutely insane to me
but then i think just in 2021 i'm looking at
some of the specs right now i do think a lot
of them are like super um overvalued so i'm just
looking at maybe some more companies like forest
road acquisition which is managing beachbody and
so they they're gonna be taking three companies
like mrx fitness as well so that's kind of a
competitive peloton and they're going to be
putting them all under this one umbrella company
which is going to be making like similar revenues
to palestine and pedestrians like so they're
going to publish a few billion dollar evaluation
person's doing something like i don't know they're
like 40 billion right now so i'm just so i'm
watching them right now obviously i think at the
moment i'm just focusing on four core positions
right now that's tesla clean spock akamoto and
peak okay i like it and you mentioned bitcoin so
you have to tell me how you initially got into
cryptocurrency um and also do your parents you
know your parents must know what you're investing
in do they have any concerns about crypto at all
no my parents don't really know what crypto is so
okay there you go yes so how did you first hear
about it yes i mean loads of my followers are
all i was kind of into bitcoin like two months
like nine months ago i hadn't really
heard of it so i hadn't really done much
research but then my followers were into when i
started picking up on the amount of followers and
all of them were like really into bitcoin so i
also do a load of research into bitcoin ethereum
i do it all on the network and honestly i've come
to the conclusion of the last few months bitcoin
is digital gold that is okay that's the currency
which we use to store value on the digital network
people don't want to see the mass inflation like
40 or those like the last two years uh have all
been printed in the us they don't want to have
their money constantly devalued as prices go up
they want to have a safe sort of value and then
they can actually transact in in the sense instead
of having a gold bar which you've got a store and
if you don't have enough space to store all your
gold bars they've got paid to store it competitors
all secure online so more and more as bitcoin
matures then you get that price volatility coming
down i've also concluded theorems digital gold you
get nfts you get tokens so this whole network
which is built around the theorem of just all
this kind of different funky weird stuff there's
come there's one called uni socks which you just
buy like socks or actual socks i haven't seen that
actually yeah so that's uni socks i i've got like
i don't know 100 bucks it's super sensitive but
basically uni socks were done by the thing called
uni swap which is one of the creators in the um
ethereum network which is creating code for it and
they issued much one time about a year a year ago
something so the merch is all it's actual socks
i did see this i remember yeah all has uni socks
on it so they sold it for about 12 bucks they're
not nice you know no no they're nothing special
just socks of uni socks on it yeah just about
a year a year and a half ago they sold it for 12
bucks i think that's like 8 800 000 it hit a high
of 136 thousand dollars for a pair of socks which
is which is kind of insane it says about like 478
of them right now which haven't been redeemed so
if you get what if you have like one pair of socks
you can redeem like one pair of socks you can
actually wear them and have it all sent to your
dress for free so that's really the whole concept
unison so it's just one of those smaller things
in the whole network which is super duper funky
it's just got so many use cases around the theorem
but there is going to be more of a case so you're
going to have this nfts you're going to have all
this kind of stuff built around it but then people
aren't going to be people will be buying ethereum
as a store of value but also in a sense to be
able to transact on the whole network itself
so okay so so many interesting things there so
firstly i do remember the socks um that was pretty
crazy i remember when that came out but okay so
bitcoin you obviously see is as digital gold you
mentioned ethereum as a store of value that's
really interesting um because a lot of people
sort of see bitcoin more as that store of value
and ethereum there's like currency kind of thing
yeah like network itself in my opinion yeah just
you know like programmable money and well somebody
wants to put it to me like this somebody wants to
put it to me as um bitcoin is gold and ethereum
is amazon the same way you can literally at this
point do anything on amazon whether it's you know
watch a film um buy things you know and those
two things are completely different so where do
you see all the other cryptocurrencies you
know are would you obviously not a bitcoin
maximalist you obviously see a lot of value in d5
and nfts so tell me where you see the most value
i think nfc is a bubble i think all great
things start with the bubble we saw a
bitcoin back in 2017. my opinion on nfts
is a sense it's just one so over hope now
and i think they will crash eventually but
then in five years six years down the road
you're going to see another surge in nf teaser
like we saw in bitcoin like we saw all the other
cryptocurrencies back in the day i think all great
things started the bubble and then it's slowly
going to build its way back up as we've seen the
bitcoin this year and in 2020 it started to all
build it about itself it back up from this kind of
2017 2018 kind of crashes from its all-time highs
it's like 18 000 and then you have everything
like selling out of it and so now in the sense
bitcoin is now owned by institutions bitcoins now
owned by tesla which is an s p 500 company it's
been now officially hated in a sense where back
then in 2017 it wasn't like mainstream accepted
by the whole society i think nfts is not having a
flow of institutional money coming into it so i do
think some nfts will survive and will be valuable
some of the original nfts a majority of them will
lose more or less all their value and maybe in
a few years they want to really stand out which
innocence are actual artwork you know there's no
art but on on the digital if somebody sees a value
in the piece of art because they think it's a
phenomenal piece of art they actually love it
it's all on digital and they want to own that one
copy of it all online and they could buy that nft
so you'll see that you're actually going to have
in the future way more kind of entity artists in a
sense you're going to see your bank season they're
all going to be developing on nfts this is all six
years down the road it's not now i think it's all
starting to become a bit like you've got load of
entities out it's kind of just pointless and it
goes for hundreds and hundreds of thousands so
and that's why i really do see nfts i think the
biggest store of value in the cryptocurrency
right now which will make the most is bitcoin i
think yeah when my price tag on bitcoin's 300 000
i'm just doing it around the market have
gold right now so that's around like 300k
so i know people like pomp think it's going
to a million i'm not i'm not that full but
i'm not full-blown bitcoin maximalist right now
but i do just think it's gonna because such be
such a superior sort of value i mean peter schiff
tweeted today that he finally accepted him but he
was wrong about bitcoin as an april fools i think
the jokes can be on him in like a few years and
he actually does accept it if he let me ask you
about that let me ask you about like is i think
so there's this narrative right that bitcoin is
the new gold and i find it so fascinating how
they say it's easier to sell bitcoin as an
investment to your generation than it is to
sell gold as an investment i mean you even said at
the beginning of this um in the beginning of the
podcast you said um you know you can't carry it
around with you it's difficult to transact in so
although it's pretty gold it's nice and shiny
um you know it's not really something which
the next generation are gonna care that much
about bitcoin is an easier sell don't you think
yeah literally no no one cares about gold in
anyone who i know i think bitcoin in my era
look at okay it's a perfect example peter schiff
has a son called spencer the guy's the biggest
bitcoin maximus i've ever seen he's all in on
bitcoin 100 bitcoin i think that really kind of
does show that kind of stark difference between
somebody like spencership who's way younger in
university right now this dad who's proper into
bitcoin you know now and he's i don't know what
the ship is probably like 50 60 now so it's kind
of the point where the younger generation's just
embracing bitcoin now if you have asked kids about
my my age about bitcoin most of them are going to
have no clue just because you know they're that
young they're not really interested in stuff
now but older and older it's going to be kind of
bitcoin will be way more accepted than gold 100
you know the older you get you're going
to get people your friends are going to be
let's say in at least five years your friends are
going to be bugging you about how to invest i'm
absolutely telling you they're going to be bugging
you because you have all the answers and i mean
even my family have been bugging me about
bitcoin and i don't have all the answers um
you know i have some of the answers i have
don't have all of them but your friends are
going to be absolutely bugging you um but anyway
why do you why do you think then people like
peter schiff can't get on board even people
like warren buffett what's the problem well
i think instead of stuck in the past you know
they live with gold for their whole life and
a brand new revolutionary digital currency comes
along they've seen the growth of the internet and
in the one sense from the early 2000s to now
as many people i mean like you're asian those
people have seen the growth of the internet now
yeah but it's all they've all seen it progress
but i think especially when you're older you may
be in like 70s 60s it's a lot harder to accept
especially being really passionate about saying
gold your whole life even if you start to kind of
crave into bitcoin you're always going to incent
to always reject it rejects it just because one
thing in your mind it's always like gold is
physical i can see gold i can i can hold it i
can hold it up i can break it whatever that may be
but i actually have it i can have it still running
in my room i can have a story in my vault i've
got it in it physically whenever they struggle
see bitcoin is selling something which is on
the internet so you or or in the bitcoin network
so they struggle to see how you can actually
touch it and how it has physical value like i'm
recording on the mac right now i can touch my i
can touch i can you know do the keyboard whatever
or doing a mouse but the point is that this
is all physical and they struggle to accept
that and stuff's just moving online it's all
moving online now they just can't see that all
happening and they just they just can't accept it
so in a sense i think they've had a bit stuck in
the past and maybe they were great once but maybe
they're kind of like falling behind the times now
yeah i think it's so hard when you made your
fortune and you made your wealth doing one
thing and then something new comes along and
it's just easier to just say no that's rubbish
because you don't want to have to adopt and and
sorry adapt and change and they always say you
can't teach an old dog new tricks so maybe you
know it's something like that i mean even my dad
when tesla um invested into bitcoin i i was
going crazy i was like wow this is so insane
and i told my dad and his first response was so
when are you selling and i'm like oh you don't
get it this means hold even tighter you know um so
i yeah i think it's so interesting um and i think
you know i i was actually telling my grandfather i
mean he's he's 93. i was telling him about bitcoin
and um he thought it was criminal and he his first
response was does your father know what's going on
it's crazy you know um so what are you
holding then you're holding bitcoin right
can you tell us anything else yes i'm having
bitcoin ethereum right now and i got some kind
of funky tokens some people sent me on on
the ethereum network so i've just already
got bitcoin ethereum right now it's probably
like a six or sixty forty split right now so i
just i'm really big on crypto in the one sense
i think it's the next kind of store of wealth
i do think bitcoin is going to be a place where
it's always going to be that store you know you
see mass and adoption sets that people might be
able to pay with bitcoin and you know i think as
the sun's people talk about the risk that bitcoin
might get deregulated or regulation will come in
i think governments love bitcoin because it's
open to secure they can see all the transactions
happening on it i just think the only reason
governments would regulate it or do anything
incentive regulation is just to get a fair share
of the taxes side of it yeah that's all all the
only thing governments are really concerned about
they just want their fair share of the taxes
you're gonna for example you might see a bitcoin
being abandoned um pakistan or somewhere where in
the in the east completely get somewhere here
which is a lot more you know completely open
you know open speech you know you can have
protests you've got all this kind of free speech
the western in the west so it's kind of like
they won't it'd be harder to really push a ban
on bitcoin but i don't think it's risk of a ban
now it's just where they want their taxes and
where they want to introduce something i do think
that's the only really real risk with bitcoin
is also supply bitcoins completely based on supply
and demand you have to have supply and demand for
bitcoin with somewhere like tesla if tesla builds
a gigafactories tesla does well in autonomy
attest makes in billions of trillions wherever
from all their business sectors tesla stock
prices rise with it obviously but comparison and
bitcoin it does have to be that mass adopted so
in a sense you've got to have constant supply and
demand for it and yeah i think i think that's what
i'm seeing right now it's more and more people
starting to hear about bitcoin and realize bitcoin
has come away from that lesser legal activity
now and all that sort of illegal activity and
it's now talking to how it's about has such a
phenomenal story of value so i do think bitcoin's
got the most potential of bitcoin ethereum i
think ethereum's potential is where you've got
the whole network everything built around that
network you should transact with it you can buy
paint you can write online paintings now for nfts
you can find all these amazing kind of things all
these funky things you can buy new kind of coins
on the ethereum network are they gonna be worth
anything or not that's a different question such
a whole kind of whole layer around the theorem
then you're gonna see ethereum two and then
hopefully you're gonna get gas prices lowered
so i think that's a one thing stopping
the theorem from really having a breakout
it's just how much gas costs because it's
kind of insane a few years ago like last
year it would cost a few bucks that's like 20
30 bucks if i wanted to buy a coin or whatever
so i think is if you get the gas prices down with
their room too but all the new updates coming to
ethereum then you can really see mass adoption on
the side of ethereum so i do think that's where to
potentialize i say longer term bitcoin does have
the most chance of being successful i think if a
theorem can get in there near the popularity
of bitcoin and people start to accept as kind
of a whole transaction network then you could
see a theorem really take off alongside bitcoin
yeah i think you make a really interesting
point just going back to the point about um
regulation um because i think it does come down
to governments kind of wanting their fair share
and wanting to get their cut um because like you
said you know there was this concern initially
that bitcoin was um the best answer the best
vehicle for criminal activity and as we know
with blockchain technology that's obviously not
the case everything can be tracked and traced and
cash is far better um you know to use if you want
to like launder money or whatever it is um so yeah
that narrative has definitely been broken down i
think so in nigeria they they they put some they
put some heavy regulations there which stopped
people from trading and then i ended up trading
at a premium but i think they actually went back
on that i need to check it out but i think they
reversed it because they sort of realized that
these are something called to even get more
bitcoin everything like 90 grand a bitcoin even
that's really illegal in nigeria just so they can
actually own bitcoin so i think yeah in african
countries is there for bitcoin you know bitcoin
could be a solution to africa some of africa's
poverty in the sense i don't go fully with some
of that kind of argument i see people always sing
saying our book was the answer to africa after the
super poor in itself so i think the first thing
about afro is actually getting all that technology
into it so i mean like starlink could really solve
that as you can guess it without building all the
buyers you kind of all beam down from the skies
because they said more more spacex rockets into
the sky which gets startling a huge advantage so i
think the main focus of africa in a sense is just
technology um and growing but then if you start
getting get in the face with more technology going
to africa which i think is really last continent
to be taken up to some sort of modern standards
how how the west is living or maybe somewhere
in asia or or even china in that sense as soon
as you get kind of that standard sign taking up
for all the african countries then you could see
bitcoin become a solution to africa and helping
more people get our poverty in africa but that's
that's my view on that i don't know what your
original thing was well no i totally agree with
you that's one of the main things actually
that drew me to this space initially it was
literally blockchain in africa like bitcoin aside
there's this whole blockchain in africa movement
and i'm actually fascinated by it because there's
this idea that africa are going to skip industrial
revolutions and you know are just going to be
totally um unbanked and that'd be absolutely fine
but i think that's where defy comes in a little
bit and i'm not i'm really kind of uncomfortable
with d5 i like it i get it but i think it's really
hard to i find it quite hard to navigate and you
know and know what's good and what's not honestly
there's just been so many rug pulls but um i was
actually doing an interview with a company
called um i think it's called zend finance
and um they're huge in nigeria and i didn't know
this but apparently there are there are limits
about how much you're maybe allowed to spend or
trade i can't remember but apparently there's like
a hundred dollar a day limit on on on something in
nigeria and i was absolutely blown away and these
d5 protocols are out there making a difference
and you know i thought that was insane honestly
yeah i mean i think d5 has got potential
by you i just find it quite hard to you
know go through all of it yes see what
is which what is good or bad so i think
one day i need you to see a full blown thing into
d5 i just spend like the instead of looking at
stocks it's just like d5 d5 d3 then kind of get
your head around it and actually decide what's
good or bad i mean right now i just stick with
kind of my core kind of thing which is bitcoin
in my in my kind of mind i've got
my i've got my theory my 640 split
but i'm super big on kind of bitcoin that's like
the main thing i think i actually own some um gbtc
which is basically bitcoin on the ethereum network
it's backed by one bitcoin so you basically follow
the exact price of bitcoin and i said i own some
of that as my bitcoin holding as well i think
nice that's amazing i'm sure there have been some
amazing comments by the way just to let you know
i'm sure somebody will um give you a defy give you
some d5 tips in the comments i'm sure someone will
reach out to you so guys follow young investor
he's absolutely amazing and give him some deep
eye tips but i wanted to ask you have you were you
following the robin hood scandal with gme and amy
yeah i mean i was kind of vocal in the kind of
robin hood scandal i think gme i mean it's just
like 100 something dollars right now i think the
first one i think the first run of wall street
bets it's brilliant you know it's squeezing it
to a short as they manipulated your stock prices
for such a long time in a sense now it's becoming
kind of a new face of the best thing which i can't
say you don't want it's going to face investing
as wall street bets that's not you're not doing
i mean look at you know something like
keith mcgill who's wrong kissy you know
um all on reddit and all that the really first
person to be proper into and gme at four dollars
he'd done his research he concluded was super
duper undervalued and he's done like he did
hours of dcf modeling on on the thing on all his
live streams from back in the day there's one live
stream which only got some like one person
for like a four hour live stream in the chat
so i think he was just looking at those stocks as
the kind of thing where jimmy's super undervalued
and wall street and he started posting on wall
street bets read it the wall street bets was it is
really first of a big pump of wall street bets to
actually profit influencing the stock market and
going beyond the realm of penny stocks and into
the big cap stocks it's like worth a two billion
dollars such as gma i don't think the second the
second time around which you'll sing with a lot of
the companies maybe it's kind of bit where it's
become the face of investing and then so many
people lost money from the jeremy's uh all the gme
saga yeah there's some random security guys like
2060 he said 11 000 loan which was all his net
worth in which he had done it all on to put him
all in jimmy like three hundred bucks which is a
bit it's coming that's insane and you lost it all
obviously so it's kind of thing where it's kind of
becoming the new face of it whether that's good or
not i do think robin are blocking the trains it's
like super there's something shady going on in the
sense but it's time to think whether it's actually
robinhood or not because originally then i was
kind of all set on its robin hood but after doing
a bit more research into it it seems in my eyes uh
somebody at citadel who's holding the trainings
for robin hood it wasn't just robin had affected
robertson got slack but we bought they all shut
they should all shut it down apart from so far
so i do think that looking at all um i think
maybe there's something shady going on that
might be through citadel so it's something like
citadel securities which is the transaction
of all the kind of inflow of orders which i'm
sending every day or whatever you send every day
and which is transacting them by themselves
and then citadel which is a hedge fund they
both own the same company but they said there's no
collusion there's obviously some sort of collusion
the ceo is the exact same with both companies
there's absolutely no inclusion they said so
there's definitely been collusion somewhere in
my eyes in the network with the problem solely
to blame for that i don't i don't i'm not
too sure if that's really the truth of it
yeah i was watching um an interview that the
c ceo did i think was his name vlad vladimir
or something like that yeah vlad so he didn't
interview i think it was with cnbc and do you ever
get when you're watching someone really closely
and you're trying to listen to every single word
they're saying to really try and understand
and i swear to you he said nothing i really
got no you know they asked them was it problem
liquidity no it wasn't a problem with liquidity
um and literally absolutely nothing you know it
was so insane um but also there are some questions
for you in the chat so i'm wondering would
you want to do a little ama really quickly
are you cool with that far right okay guys
so if you have any questions for our young
investor drop them in the chat now so there are
some really interesting ones um and one which i
wanted to ask you but i actually forgot myself
so here we go wondering if he had any issues
opening up trading accounts because of his age
this kid is impressive totally agree or really
cool so did you have any uh age restrictions
and even on twitter is there an age minimum
age so like i'm in like the twitter restrictions
we're just you know just right now but yeah with
the trading account kind of their story so i just
got my mom to open the trading account so just do
all of that now my mom's got like no clue what i
do my trading account is just like whatever you
know she's got absolutely no clue about anything
about finance at all so i just got my mom to open
it so i can do it myself obviously because i
don't pay taxes and i'm not yet 18. i think it
should be like something like 16 just because
that's 16 you start paying taxes anyway so it's
kind of like well if you pay taxes you should be
allowed to invest in stock market legally anyway
about 18 then i'll probably i'd probably just
transfer it all to my when i open a new account
at 18. i'll just get it all transferred over
there and just send it directly um i think you
can't say your stocks now i'm really doing the
state so i had to check with my broker in the uk
i love that you have that that's so funny yeah
i mean it's totally the same thing i remember
when i was when i was younger this sounds really
weird because usually i'm always the youngest in
the room so this is a really strange experience um
but when i was opening up a facebook account back
in like 2006 2007 i wasn't old enough either so i
feel like most the people on social media aren't
on old enough everybody sort of like jokes about
their age but there are a few more questions
someone says how old is he it's a goal for those
that don't know 30. uh by 10 13 like two weeks
ago now so yeah it's been so yeah so 13 two weeks
ago last sunday and then i got my new um mac for
my like birthday which is like a warm up for the
birthday present so that's what i do i'm waiting
to use on now so before i'd used to use like my
uh my little phone but now it's like really all
improved quality you know got the microphone and
everything so really improved quality in terms
of your camera in terms of what's my what's your
first big loss and for how did you react i don't
like i haven't had a you know like a big big loss
which would be sizeable i might have lost like 10
more stocking i've sold before i haven't really
experienced that big loss i'm sure i will at some
point but i think just because you've invested for
nine months it's always been a super bull market
for the last nine months i don't think it's kind
of a bit harder unless you're going super all in
on penny stocks or kind of a hype play i might
have gotten to maybe one or two kind of stocks
for like i don't know 50 bucks into it's kind of
a super sweat play where i might have lost i know
like 10 percent or whatever there's nothing
really which in my core portfolio which i've
actually lost loads of money on okay cool let's
have a look what else we've got here um so many
questions all right i'm gonna i'm trying to get
some friendly ones here we go what do you look
for when investing in altcoins specifically defy
tokens we did kind of touch on this but go for it
yeah so when i kind of look i'm looking for
something which has been around for a while
number one i'm not i don't want to buy something
completely new so use socks it's kind of the main
thing i mean i look at socks and stuff which was
original experiment about one or two years ago
super not hyped at all so socks has started seven
for twelve dollars there's an experiment it's
literally experiment with the craziest uni swap
hayden adam jones and all the guys over there
and they did this huge experiment and the guy
i know who i did i think once mike the maurice
he brought into he brought some like 10 socks that
sound like 12 bucks he's like yes he's what i call
the only socks maximalist in the entire world he's
like full blown socks he wears socks he wears uni
socks on it he wears like thousand dollar socks
he's like full blown that he's like full blown
socks so i think unlike something it can be copied
like there's stuff on the network can be not
exactly copied by some of the codes or something
like uni socks yeah somebody else can release
their own kind of socks i think something like
that which has been on network for way longer than
all the new kind of things coming into it it's
something which is really cool and i've i haven't
brought any efts yet i'm kind of browsing some
like i know kelly from hyperchain troy interviewed
he when he buys nfts it's not because he wants
to make money on them he actually appreciates
what they are what the artwork is so i'm not super
involved in d5 right now i do i just i think i
just need to do a few miles of digging into it i'm
going to conclude what is that greatest what's the
best and what is the worst why do you think it's
more maybe established stuff right now yeah well
you're getting a great fan base here so i'm sure
some no i'm sure somebody's going to come and help
you with some defy info um here's another good one
where did it go i want to put it up on the screen
here we go what's his hottest penny stock drop
yeah so the kind of one like one which i got
super high conviction i am like a few it's like
five percent of my portfolio i mean it's super
high indexes peak it's not a fully full-blown
penny stock but it's around 300 million dollar
market cap so it will move like a penny stock also
one of the things i will add to people as i talked
about earlier is how well the stock price holds up
in terms of you get a correction or something you
know the whole market scene in town turn peak
during when all the growth stocks like tesla
they're all down like five percent plus people
sounds like 0.88 so i also think peak's really
the only penny stock i've seen where people invest
and actually know what they're invested in they've
actually done their loads of research for it so
i think people are like top one i won't repeat
everything i said but if you just wind it back
then you can see what i was saying i'm gonna go
all right and just last question for
you um because i want to dig in on this
right at the end do you plan to leave school asap
ah what great question no i like i'm probably
gonna say school to like six months or something
but further education university maybe not maybe
i'll just see how it goes but yeah i think i
feel like some of my friends did homeschooling
like after they left primary school or something
yeah i didn't really keep in touch with them
they're not super good friends and so i think
home school is coming we just kind of lose social
contact with people i think it's always good
to be in contact with people you know have that
kind of social interaction social interaction
because we see with you know covered when you
don't interact with people and how much it damages
people's mental health and all that kind of stuff
so i think school's always like a
great place to go to but maybe not even
maybe not further education i think you're so
intelligent and i think that you are in the most
incredible position i've ever seen someone of your
age be in you know not just you're not not just
having an understanding of finance and being able
to trade but also your understanding of the world
um you know like i was saying earlier on twitter
there's so much conversation um conversation about
the world right like even conversation about covid
and how we as people should react to that you
know and whether it's our responsibility or your
responsibility and all this stuff and i just think
having exposure to these kind of conversations
i'm just honestly so blown away i think you're
absolutely incredible somebody's just written
lol she's interviewing a millionaire kid already
i mean i won't ask you about that but no i
i think you're honestly so fantastic and um
i just want to wish you the best of luck
with everything that you do and also
one thing that i will say is um just continue
to do what you're doing don't let anybody pull
you off track don't let you know people will be
jealous and just stay focused do what you're doing
um because i i've never ever seen someone so
intelligent and just so on it and so worldly
at such a young age i think it's fantastic
so there you go those are my thoughts um
what are you up to now and how can people reach
out to you yeah so you can watch my youtube
channel which is young investor i've had a few
guests on recently go watch watch go watch like
three videos ago like i was doing those stock
videos so you're watching on there or you can
follow me out at investor2 on twitter or just
just like a young investor i should be like near
this top or first search result when you look
that up so yeah that's really my like two main
feeds and i've also got discord group there's
a link on the pinned um comment and my twitter
there you go i want to thank you so
much it's been such a pleasure and um
guys don't forget to follow him he's a
little genius he'll make you a genius
um so guys give him a follow and thank you
all for tuning in i will see you next week bye
uh